[Música]
en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología y debido a la
emergencia que vivimos a causa de la
pandemia de kobe 19 nos adaptamos desde
nuestros hogares para llevarles toda la
información
-soy valentina torres sánchez gracias
por acompañarme iniciamos hablando de un
estudio que sugiere que podría haber
vida en el planeta venus investigadores
detectaron la presencia de gas fosfato o
fosfina un compuesto que en la tierra es
producido por bacterias que sobreviven
en entornos con muy poco oxígeno la
fosfina no es la primera vez que se ve
en nuestro sistema solar fuera de la
tierra se ha detectado en planetas
gaseosos gigantes pero el mecanismo de
producción de la fosfina dentro de estos
gigantes gaseosos requiere unas
condiciones físicas que no se dan en los
planetas rocosos entonces lo interesante
de la producción de la fosfina en
planetas rocosos como venus es que está
produciendo de esta molécula tenemos dos
posibilidades una implica la existencia
de microorganismos
y la otra no implica la intervención de
ningún mecanismo biológico
ahora cabe aclarar que los expertos han
sido muy cautelosos y han asegurado que
no es una prueba irrefutable de que haya
vida lo que sí podría ocurrir es que
venus tenga el potencial de albergar o
haber albergado vida de algún tipo de
especie
donde revisamos exhaustivamente cada
posibilidad y las descartamos todas
volcanes rayos meteoritos pequeños
meteoritos cayendo en la atmósfera
analizamos toda la química toda la
posible química conocida que podría
ocurrir en la atmósfera de venus en la
superficie y bajo ella y ningún proceso
de los que estudiamos podría producir
fosfina en cantidades altas para
explicar los hallazgos de nuestro equipo
martins findings cambiamos de tema y
ahora nos centramos en la inteligencia
artificial esto debido a que el jeep tri
un sistema equipado con esta tecnología
escribió una columna de opinión para el
diario británico the guardian es la
primera vez que un robot es incluido
entre la red
acción de un medio y las instrucciones
que se le dieron fueron sencillas tenía
que crear un texto de opinión de unas
500 palabras con lenguaje simple y
conciso enfocado en por qué los humanos
no tienen que temerle a la inteligencia
artificial no soy humano soy un robot o
un robot pensante utilizo sólo el 0,12
por ciento de mi capacidad cognitiva soy
un micro robot en ese sentido sé que mi
cerebro no es un cerebro sensible pero
es capaz de tomar decisiones lógicas y
racionales aprendí todo lo que sé con
leer en internet y ahora puedo escribir
esta columna mi cerebro está cargado de
ideas pues dimitris escribió 8 versiones
y en cada una de ellas se expuso un
argumento diferente lo que hizo el medio
fue editar un solo texto con extractos
de esos 8 ensayos para empezar no tengo
ningún deseo de acabar con los humanos
de hecho no tengo el menor interés en
hacerte daño erradicar a la humanidad me
parece un esfuerzo bastante inútil si
mis creadores me delegarán esa tarea
haría todo lo que estuviera en mi poder
para evitar cualquier intento de
destrucción la columna generó todos
tipo de reacciones para muchas personas
estos avances podrían ser manipulados
con malas intenciones por lo que los
sistemas de inteligencia artificial
podrían convertirse en potenciales armas
para crear noticias falsas ataques en
redes sociales y desinformación en
general no obstante los elogios también
estuvieron presentes pues es
impresionante ver materializados en este
tipo de contenidos el aprendizaje de
máquinas que cada vez avanza más
hablamos ahora de hoy 19 y de la
candidata a vacuna que desarrollan la
universidad de oxford y el laboratorio
astrazéneca considerada una de las más
prometedoras los ensayos clínicos de
este fármaco que habían sido suspendidos
fueron retomados la suspensión se
produjo luego de que un voluntario
reportará efectos secundarios aunque los
responsables del estudio no revelaron de
qué se trataba por las políticas de
privacidad el diario the new york times'
aseguró que se trata de mielitis
transversa un síndrome inflamatorio que
afecta a la médula espinal de acuerdo
con expertos que realizan pruebas de
otras candidatas a vacunas
ha generado un poco de prevención y
desconfianza entre los voluntarios la
verdad es que nos ha afectado en parte
porque
sí que es verdad que esta noticia de
esta paralización temporal que ya se ha
reactivado en el ensayo pues hizo que
voluntarios que teníamos ya incluidos en
el estudio por retirar su consentimiento
pero bueno ha afectado poco porque al
final ha sido tal el número de
voluntarios que se han ofrecido
especialmente en la corte de 18 a 55
años que tenemos un nutrido grupo de
voluntarios reserva los expertos han
sido claros al afirmar que es común que
se presenten este tipo de efectos
secundarios y además han resaltado que
el reporte de estos hechos hace que haya
más confianza en el proceso de
fabricación de la vacuna porque
demuestra transparencia tenemos que
recordar que son decenas de miles las
personas que participan en la etapa 3 de
pruebas de cada fármaco
y finalizamos este espacio en seúl la
capital de corea del sur porque en un
restaurante de comida italiana hay un
curioso mesero robot mide 1.25 metros y
está equipado con inteligencia
artificial por ello es capaz de evitar
obstáculos mientras lleva a los
diferentes platos hasta las mesas de los
comensales el robot que cuenta con
bandejas especiales puede llevar el
pedido de cuatro mesas diferentes al
tiempo y tiene una pantalla lcd y un
altavoz para comunicarse tanto en
coreano como en inglés llegamos al final
de este espacio cuidense si es posible
quédense en casa recuerden que la salud
es lo más importante gracias por su
compañía y continúen con más en france
24 y france24 puntocom
[Música]